it is time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share items that might help
make your day a little bit better a
little brighter as well all at exclusive
discounts and to start shopping right
now all you got to do is scan the QR
code on your screen upper left there or
visit cbsdeals.com meanwhile lifestyle
host Gail bass joins us now to talk us
through the deals today and this is what
you were shown off in the Green Room oh
yeah this is the calming heat XXL you
want to go to cbsdeals.com now because
this one always sells out because it is
fantastic you feel how warm it is if you
can reach over Nate feel how warm that
is I feel underneath comforting embrace
it is weighted it is it massages and
it's heated this is great for me because
I love to hike I get to soar back all
the time and traveling a lot I pick up a
lot of suitcases the wrong way right I
lay on that and I love it I remember
telling you my dog used to love curling
up on it me out the way it is a great
Pad but this one is super size so this
is something you want to get and it's 40
off so you can get it for 53.99 so go to
cbsdeals.com right now because this
stuff sells out you should send a couple
to Oprah she has new knees she likes
hiking she always needs a deal oh honey
Oprah can have whatever she wants I will
make sure that happens that looks good
all right now the scale this is the
counto and this is from re-athlete and I
like the scale because it has a phone
app you should really get on your scale
every day people don't like to do that
but as I'm trying to keep up with my try
to keep up with my weight loss plan I
get on it every day and what I could do
is I could look at the phone and not
only can I see my weight in my progress
it has 12 measurements so it can measure
body mass visceral fat really it's
subcutaneous fat or 12 measurements so
if you're an athlete or if you're really
serious about your weight loss program
or just want to know where you are on
any Baseline this is a great tool to
check your weight parameters stop
putting your feet on here just by
putting your feet on here and it uses
just a little bit of a biomedical
science to like send electricity through
your body not electricity but electrodes
to they send like little waves of
electricity through there and does it
does it does it measure Point tenths of
a pound I like that so you know if
you're 171.2 that's what I was this
morning I like it when it's point
something yeah as opposed to rounding up
yeah they though it does something
something and like this is absolutely I
want it safe to stand on does it talk to
you uh it'll talk to you just by reading
the numbers that talks to you every time
good news first it's in the bed yeah the
good news is is that you're paying
attention right that's always good news
and we have this for 38 off so this is
going to be 49.99 and again this is safe
for people to stand on because all it's
doing is just sending modes through your
through your fat and your water and
it'll tell you what your body mass is I
like that I need that one yeah I'm gonna
try this one out I would like one all
right what do we have over here so
apparently there's a big game coming up
and Hollywood's having a big night yeah
so people are going to have potlucks
this is a great way to take something
that's easy to cook and it has something
for everyone this is from opapa Oppo pop
and what I love about it is is that it
has so many different flavors and it's
easy to make and these kernels are
infused with flavors so you don't have
to shake salt or butter or anything on
them they already come flavored you just
tear open the packet okay you pour it in
the bowl this bowl right here that
collapses yeah you pour it in this bowl
and then you heat it up in the microwave
and it's done this bowl is reusable you
can put it in the microwave obviously
and it's you can put it in the
dishwasher I like it well I've tried the
fancy butter and the cinnamon I like all
the different flavors Gail oh I love
them
fancy butter yeah that's right yes thank
you for sharing Tony questions
[Laughter]
this morning the smell was so good it is
wonderful popcorn always has a wonderful
but I like this is all self-contained
yes drop it in here
right there right there you put the lid
on you pop it and I love how easily it
cleaned because I thought oh all that
Maui heat juices it's going to stain it
it didn't then you just reorder the
packets yes you can reorder the packets
this kit that we have it's uh it starts
at 33.50 and we have it for starting at
26 off but hey you know when you go to
that uh big Hollywood night party and
everybody names their food after movies
yes we just say every popcorn everywhere
all over the floor once everybody gets
done that's a thing they keep telling me
I gotta stay over here because I'm in
the shop but I want to eat the popcorn
yeah come on very nice game yeah I
appreciate it for you very good that's a
good good price for this yeah oh
absolutely don't worry about bags
sometimes you never know what happens in
the microwave piggle does it ever burn
this is the thing with yeah that I have
with microwave popcorn yeah it will burn
if you put it on for like five minutes
and then walk away but if you follow
directions well yeah yeah this kit is a
great idea that's awesome yeah I'm so
glad your cooking skills include the
microwave yeah that's about it Tony
that's about it I could I think I could
actually do this all right you Gail
you're welcome thank you thank you again
much appreciate it and of course we do
partner with all these companies to get
the deals we just mentioned and if you
want to buy anything you saw today all
you got to do is scan the QR code on
your screen right now upper left or head
over to cbsdeals.com to start shopping
right now we will be right back and I'll
be eating some popcorn